yeah when i was young it you know it
wasn't
it wasn't there i mean i remember when
butterscotch first hit the scene and
they didn't it just people people were
shocked
you know people they didn't know what to
do i remember
you know people covering their
children's eyes and
you know people just hanging garlic on
their door
and all the people it just because it
had never been
you know this is back when they only had
a certain amount of flavors
in existence you know they had
strawberry and they had vanilla they had
uh
chocolate those are easy that's basic
that's your natural three you know and
then somebody come along with a mint
somebody come along with a banana
and you know when then the the flavor
the flavor uh
the palate you know the flavor rainbow
was getting thicker
and then somebody added in uh i don't
even know what they added in at that
point peanut butter bacon
you know um raspberry some [ __ ] said
hey what about raspberry and people said
oh
all right dang it
and things was getting wild and then i
remember butterscotch hit
and i remember where i was man i was in
second grade and
i was in math class i didn't i didn't
know what was going on
you know they were talking about you
know addition
and subtraction and i just
i mean my world was just starting to
damn fall apart
and uh and somebody handed me one of
them
one of them bs's baby just wrapped up in
a beautiful little
cellophane skirt you notice in a little
damn plastic straight jacket just sealed
off at both ends
and i opened that bastard up and i put
it in my mouth and i just
it was like somebody had just i mean it
was butter and scotch
you know it just people didn't know
it did you you nobody done anything like
this
you know maybe you'd seen it written on
a toilet wall or something
you know larry loves butter and larry
loves scotch
but you'd never see larry loves butter
scott you wouldn't see
it just peep it just and then it hit the
scene and it was
you know all the fatties all the thicket
thicks out there wanted that butter and
all the drunken drips out there wanted
that scotch
and you'd see people fist fighting for
them
you know you'd see people just beating
their damn step-daddies with a freaking
you know just be you you see somebody
beating somebody else with a damn bike
chain
for a damn werthers you know it was just
it was a different time baby it was a
different time man
god is good brother let's get into it
gang
[Music]
outdoors
gas on the front
[Music]
come on
damn that right there is the
north mississippi all-stars
and a beautiful conglomerate of
sound and emotion there called drunk
outdoors and that is um
off their album up and rolling
and uh they they included that
uh they they were thinking about us when
they put this this hit together
and i was in a bathroom this weekend and
i saw a poster for them on the wall
as i was holding my penis and and um
and urinating and that's beautiful man
um
good to be here with you and it is uh
it is another week we start
just tumbling down the hill
just rattling along the road
you know we are that tumbleweed
heavy on the tumble baby
heavy on the weed as well
and we just keep riding this dirty
breeze
that is this disease man
that's doing whatever you know it's out
there long
chasing these senior citizens
i mean you know a lot of seniors are
locked up right now you won't see them
as it should be um
but yeah where were you when it when a
flavor hit do you remember
do you remember where you were when you
first learned about a flavor
because i remember that butterscotch
baby
that thing came across the aisle it had
been you know probably smuggled into who
knows in a country probably from the
midwest
you know smuggled into the country but
already in the country you know kind of
deal
and it had probably been in six seven
children's hands at school
for it hit my hand
and i opened that beautiful little brown
[ __ ] up
that little mixed mofo
you know and i'd never had anything
brown in my mouth son
you know i was young you know and
and i hit you know and i put that thing
i just didn't i
it was just when you first had to take
when you first had a taste of something
new
you didn't know things could could exist
man
and i'll be i mean it's every now and
then still i got to pull my damn car
over if i think too much about a
werther's originals
if i think too much about a you know a
unique type of caramel candy i gotta
pull a damn car over
you know take a break
you know maybe listen to a little jeff
buckley or something i gotta pull the
car
over and relax
i mean you know i miss sometimes i miss
the the innovation
of being young
of being new in the world
because everything you saw was new
you saw somebody you know maybe you saw
two homeless people
you know one of them ripping and the
other ones tooth out
out by the donut shop doing bootleg
dental
and it yeah but it was beautiful it was
new
you know maybe you see a man hugging
somebody in his family too hard
yeah but you know you hadn't you you'd
never seen it like that
it was new
you know you just things were different
you just i there was i liked the novelty
of being a youthful and of just of
nouveau of things being exciting there's
something beautiful about that
of somebody hitting you with that with a
new taste
here's a spare rib and you're like what
is this is it you know
i thought it was from the dang bible
when i read it on a menu
i said well damn is it you know is this
the does the church run this place
then my mom say no this this damn ground
patty junior this ain't
the church i have nothing to do with
this joint
you know just ignorance and and
and and dining that's when it all merged
um what's going on i've just
just i got back from nashville i had a
nice time
some people say nashville some people
say nashville
and people that say nashville are
obviously
out of their damn tongues brother you
know that
but i had a nice time and i went out
there to percy priest
uh lake
camping lake area kind of place you can
go missing easy that kind of joint
went out there swimming just you know i
wanted to get in that local water
i want i like i like to you know i want
to that's the kind of place i'll
cure your jock it you know
that kind of thing you know you dip
locally bro you
do you won't scratch man
because every uh june and july i really
come along that southern you know that
summer
i got that summer scratch going
and one half of the inside of my you
know near my body near my
you know near my little my little life
bag my little hot sack there
you know near my little
them jolly ranchers you know near my
nuts and i get
jock itch around them and there's no
shame in it
you know i told the man about the church
i remember when i was probably
24 i told this man i was in south
carolina and i went in there to the
little booth or whatever the photo booth
or whatever wherever you tell
the man the stuff you've been doing
that's wrong
and i said damn baby boy you know i
didn't say it just like that but i said
you know
dbb you know your honor i said i've been
i've been having you know jock itch
you know what i'm saying i've been
scratching right around the old devil's
appendix man my nuts
and uh man i think i honestly i think
the guy wanted to see my damn nuts dude
it was uh
i mean you know some of these ch you
know some of these churches when you get
really when you stop by in the daytime
that's when the real shady stuff can
happen but
um but yeah i had a beautiful time in
nashville man
you know went swimming out there percy
priest
state park i walk up and some lady just
sitting in a uh little folding chair to
yelling at all some lady
yelling at some kid named audrey audrey
audrey
and there was a little breeze i don't
think the woman could tell there was a
breeze coming in off the lake
head right it just pointing right at her
mouth so all her words were not going
very
far and this lady must have yelled
audrey
200 times audra audrey
audrey get off audrey
and little audrey brother look i ain't
saying she gonna
you know live a wild life but this
little [ __ ] didn't give a dang bro
little audrey didn't give a s-h-i-t baby
boy
audrey get over audrey
and this little smoke stack this little
lady
she was puffing on it you know she was
you know just
locomotive and on the back end of that
winston baby just hitting that sucker
hard
and uh and it was nice man i had a nice
time over there met
this white guy stopped by and he let me
drive a nice he had a real cool
truck old truck this thing got it kind
of made
it's not really painted but it's almost
like they just rubbed the rust right on
the sides of it and it just
you know kind of thing you got to get a
tetanus shot if you want to switch into
third gear you know one of those old
trucks
um and yeah
just enjoyed myself man really enjoyed
myself
um what else did i do oh man
oh this was the worst dude
i hit a uh you know i hit a dog with my
car
at night i hit an animal you know a
little animal you know a fast little
animal a dog
you've seen you know a dog and um
and that dude i'm driving right and i'm
not under the influence of anything
except being a little too emotional bro
and
you know being maybe a little bit of a
[ __ ] sometimes and
you know i can't find my retainer i
haven't been able to find it for about a
month so that's the only things i'm
really under the influence of
and um and this dog this white dog
comes running i mean galloping really
i mean it almost looked like a real fast
little pony
you know real just you know just like a
damn like america's fastest little pony
like one almost like one of them little
japanese animals you see on the
instagram
when they're giving them pills over
there in japan and getting them doped up
and a little you know they got a little
cat or a little tiger little
bichon or something got his tongue
hanging out of his mouth and they gotta
squeeze his neck real hard to get his
eyes open
you know when they say he's a you know
oh he's a miracle animal or something
you know oh he's a you know everybody
loves him
yeah but he don't have any feeling in
his body you know what i'm saying that
little thing is
you know he's on somebody somas you know
he's on so many percocets this little
damn animal
little mickey or whatever his name was
little nj or whatever they call them
but anyway sorry so this dog comes just
just running and then i slam on the
brakes
and it was over they had like a
greyhound station over there and i
couldn't see it first i mean the dog was
it was in front of my car and i hit
you know and i hit it man i i didn't hit
it but i hit
i slammed on my brakes i didn't feel
anything i didn't feel a thump or a hit
or or anything man and i just was frozen
in my car
and then two people came running up you
know this one guy kind of a
kind of chocolatey kind of guy and then
this other lady
more of a rubenesque kind of white lady
you know kind of lady looked like uh
you know i don't and she didn't have a
lot of teeth i will say that i'm not
judging her
you know you don't need teeth a lot of
people teeth is overrated
you know teeth is something that's a
delicacy according to this gal you know
she didn't have any teeth she didn't
have them
i don't know who had them but but she
you know she didn't and
and anyway so they start yelling
they said they say back up back the
truck up
and man i'm just spook i'm just just
just scared man i'm just sitting so i
back up about five feet
and i'm in like an intersection it's
it's not real busy
but i'm around maybe sixth and
in mlk junior boulevard
and um and then then i see the dog and
he's laying there and he was
like a little pit bull kind of dog and
and he just wasn't moving or anything
and so i didn't know what to do man and
next thing you know the ladies over by
the window
this lady and she kind of she reminded
me of like grover like
oscar to grouch or something a little
but kind of sexier but also
you know greyhound sexy kind of
you know kind of lady that
you know she probably had skin cancer
bruh i'll be honest with you
you know if i had to guess dude
uh anyway man she's
so she starts saying uh oh he needs cpr
he needs cpr
then other people are starting to
migrate over from the bus station it's
right there so
then this other lady says i'll do cpr
for
eighty dollars and i'm like
what you know i'm thinking that
you know this is some kind of a scam a
scam or something but the dog is i mean
i saw the dog running there's no way i
don't think they could get the dog to
lay there
and pretend that you know i don't know
so
anyway i gave the lady the 80 she
started doing cpr on the dog
and um and they couldn't get it
they couldn't get it to breathe man and
uh and this is sad man the whole thing
was sad and it happened fast
and then the lady you know she was just
so angry at me
and i mean there was nothing i could
have done like i'd never seen a dog
running this
fast it was just galloping like it was
just in a damn
contest or something like a
you know just like a damn like a little
like a galloping contest or something
you know of quickness
you know like it had been going to
quickness classes and this was its you
know
mid-term and that bat you know that
little beautiful animal widow
anyway so she starts getting upset
and i don't know what she's yelling
either you know she kind of had like a
kind of like a puppet you know sometimes
if someone doesn't have any teeth in her
mouth you get a vibe that they have that
they seem like a puppet you know because
a lot of puppets they don't put teeth in
her mouth
it's just cloth and just somebody's hand
under you know
behind it and under it and so she said
that's how she was she was coming at me
and kind of
you know getting squirrely a little and
um
she said she needed money for a new dog
i gave and i gave her 60 bucks
i dropped that hard 60 on her and and i
left man
and i saw they had a officer there on
the corner
and i asked him you know what do i do
you know i
paid for the cpr i gave you know i gave
60 for the net if you know
for some animal a new animal
and um and he said look man it wasn't
your fault
you know he did help me feel a little
bit more chill about it he said it
wasn't your fault
uh but man that [ __ ] hurt my
that hurt me you know and i've had bad
luck man i hit a dog
i was late for work one time and i hit a
dog over there supposed to be at the
seafood joint
and i showed up late and i was crying
and they [ __ ] fired me
you know and they had some hot [ __ ]
that worked over there to be honest with
you no offense
you know [ __ ] but they had
you know some real [ __ ] leg over
there
so anyway man sorry i'm just i'm horny
and i'm
you know thinking about the past at the
same time but um
what else happened dude oh so yeah so
the officer said you know it didn't look
like you could have done anything
and they shouldn't have that dog down
here unleashed and
man i'd never seen this may have been
the fastest animal
you know this santa's little helper man
and um and it just
you know when i and i had another issue
when i was working on a farm a long time
ago i backed over a deer with a um
bush hog and uh
man that and that i'll never forget the
sound of that man that
so i'm sorry man i'm not you know i you
know i i i'm learning to love animals
more as i get
more adult you know i don't have any
issues with animals i have had
extraneous poor luck
around animals and around you know
animals that are trying to live
longer than
then i guess whatever you know i just
i'm not help when it comes to animals
being alive i don't
you know i don't do i don't i'm not
helpful
i guess um
but otherwise you know i had a beautiful
time in tennessee man it just
it just was a way more relaxing
environment
you know kind of hopping around and
and uh man just beautiful you get
outside of the city and you see you
driving through these neighborhoods and
you just
you see a house that is look like damn
you know like um
it just looked like a marvin gardens or
something
you know it just looked real a lot of
fancy stuff
a lot of old school looking white houses
too man like kind of real slavy type of
vibe a little bit of them you know some
of that
you know it's a little too much but
that's just
you know that's i mean that's just
kind of history kind of stuff but
but yeah you see somehow you're like
well it just
you know we should we got to do
something to
future it up a little bit you see some
old school
historical joints out there um
but but that was that man
i want to let you know the support for
this past weekend
comes from manscaped who is number one
and below the belt grooming
i'll tell you who that's manscaped
you know when i was younger you wouldn't
let anybody come near you your crotch
with a machine
but my how times have changed
you know nowadays you'll take a little
machine and put it right up next to your
wing
right up next to your pecker you know
next to your body meat bro that spitter
that penis bro manscaped
is forever changing the body grooming
game
with their perfect package 2.0
you can support support the point cast
support the point guest inside the
perfect package 2.0 you'll find an
electric trimmer called the lawn mower
it's waterproof it's skin safe
you couldn't even carve your wiener off
if you wanted to praise god baby
you know when i used to live in
mississippi
i worked on a farm over there outside of
natchez mississippi and
they had a fellow up there and his
family ran um
the ramada up there and he was high on
drugs and
took his own uh took his own penis off
one time at a barbecue when he was high
on lsd
sweeney they called him was his sweeney
was his name and they called him
eventually call him no weenie sweeney
when he took that sucker off bro
went one for one 100 percent batting at
his own crotch bro but anyway
uh the perfect package 2.0 also includes
anti-chafing
boxer briefs that keep your crotch
cool and smelling fresh all day
and look nobody knows how the summertime
can affect that stick and bag like your
boy keep jock itch at bay
it's time to get this perfect package
2.0
and to support this past weekend get 20
off and free shipping with the code
theo at manscape.com
that's right get 20 off and free
shipping with the code
t-h-e-o at manscaped.com
that's 20 off with free shipping at
manscape.com
use code theo
oh man you know oh i got to tell you how
much time right now i have uh
no smoking
man i'm grateful for this y'all gonna be
shocked
right now i have five months three days
and 17 hours cigarette
free
and sometimes i want one of them
bastards man
sometimes i want that little snake tail
bro
satan's little freaking walking stick
that cigarette you know
mother nature's dirty little dick
brought a cigarette
but i'm five months clear off of them
and i will say this it's nice
not to feel like i need to have one a
lot of times that is pretty
nice um now what i'm only 24 hours off
of
um is uh well
let's take this call right here and this
fella will kind of get into this topic a
little bit right here onwards
what's up theo this is joe from apopka
florida
what's up joey down here in florida in
you know if there's a place you want to
run you want to hide
you know florida is it a lot of
criminals at the top
criminals throughout but it's really it
gets real country up at the top and then
it gets a little more latino and then it
gets fully homoerotic down there by key
west
or k-dub they call it or gay dub they
call it down there
and um shout out too to my little god
cousin
dylan and he just came out the closet
and uh
and his dad took his truck away for two
weeks
and um that's where you know
it's that's why you know it's i think
i mean it's you know that's
that can happen you tell dad you're gay
he says well
all right you're gonna lose that truck
for
two weeks bucko you're gonna think about
this
so that [ __ ] that [ __ ] is baffling
but shout out dylan my little god
causing hitting him ubers bruh
and hitting them wieners out there bruh
live your life little daddy
you know and you know
hopefully after the two weeks you know
you get your truck back and you and your
dad can see eye to eye and everything
will be
you know moving forward but that's wild
isn't it
imagine you told your dad you're gay or
something and he goes about
oh all right you gay buddy okay
let's see you be gay without that truck
okay
so that's the most that's the most rural
[ __ ] i've ever heard
man you come out the closet you lose
your truck for two weeks man pg
pro um let's get this call anyway that
came in here right here
and the audio is a little bit low on
this sucker i don't know what's going on
what's up d.o this is joe from apopka
florida
i'm a struggling man trying to stay away
from that uh
that that single player devil's
intercourse you feel me
talking about that that jacking off
buddy
oh yeah i feel you man
yeah i feel you man baiting your own
branch
you know hunting butter with your hand
bro i feel you man and
i feel you i got about
what time is it
i got about
17 hours no masturbation right now
let's hear more sorry i interrupted you
man trying to stay away from it man
i have a girlfriend and it ruins a lot
of stuff
in the bedroom you feel me what do you
do
what should i do just
stay away from that [ __ ] man because
it's coming from me bro i feel the dark
art is coming from me
let me know oh hell yeah man
and you can even now listen one more
time you can hear a dog in the
background there
i feel the dark guards coming from me
right there let me know
right there um
yeah man well it's hard you know and i
appreciate you calling and sharing it
you know and and bringing it up man it's
that that's the hardest thing i've found
you know it's so hard to stop touching
your own penis you know because it's
hooked to your
it's hooked to you
you know it's hooked to you it's like
tying a you know a biscuit right to
the side of a fat fella's head man
you know and there's unlimited
joy in your own penis
that's that's you know i respect what
god does but at a certain point he could
have
you know he could have scaled back he
could have took a couple scoops of joy
out of your wiener
but he didn't man he was just just just
shoveling
in the joy into your own you know
your body dick man your penis
and it's too much and here's the crazy
thing about masturbation and trying not
to do it
god gave you two hands you could break
one of your hands
and still
jerk off completely fine brother still
touch yourself completely fine
and i feel you man i mean sometimes it
feels like the devil himself
picks my hands up and puts them onto
my stick man my little body gun my dick
and i hate it man you know i've been
masturbating for 20 years brother
i mean if i'd have put that time into
the piano bruh
if i'd have put that time into learning
the french horn or learning how to do
you know do juggling or whatever
magic
actually i'd probably rather just jerk
off and learn than no magic though
that's crazy
but um man i wish i had a
you know i wish i had a way for you
right now
because i don't like doing it that's the
thing that's my thing i'd rather save up
that nut
you know that bust i'd rather corral
that energy
and feel just feel the fish just
swimming against the dam
you know because that's my energy that's
my solidity man that's my chief
and here i am just you know
i mean imagine if you you know you
punched a hole in the front of your gas
tank while you're driving
be stupid
so i feel you man especially if you got
a if you got a girlfriend and stuff just
do your best i think some meditation
helps
um and just try and maybe even share
with your girls say look i want to say
look i want to apologize if we haven't
been
sexual because i've been struggling with
this
because man i've struggled with a lot
over the years
you know i used to i'd set a date up
have a have a excite
excitement for a date one evening and
then i jerk off at 6 30.
and we're supposed to meet at quarter to
eight i call it seven and i say i can't
make it i'm sick or something
but the truth was i you know
if i've already masturbated i don't care
if it's christmas
you know it's like all of my intrigue
all of my excitement
all of my hope and possibility it's all
just gnarled up in there in my chi and
backed up in my little body nuggets man
my scrotum my nuts
so
but you know talking about it the first
thing that's important and
and i'm going to try i'm going to see
what i can do man because i want to you
know there was a time there where i was
really trying to have nocturnal
emissions
you know hunting that night bust
and i want to get back there because
when you bust in a dream man that's
that's something bigger than you you
know that's something bigger than all of
us
you know that's really
that's when we win i feel like man
so best of luck to you man um this
episode i want to let you know is
brought to you by blue
chew if you've had problems in your body
or if you haven't and you just want to
feel that fervor
you want to feel just like a thousand
ants crawled into the end of your penis
and are just
looking for fun well blue
chew can help you can increase your
performance and get that extra
confidence
in bed bluechew.com
that's blue like the color blue
blue true blue chew brings you the first
chewable
with the same fda approved active
ingredients
as viagra and cialis so it's the same as
them big guns man
but this that one maybe just that
chewable finally you get that little
snack
piece and say if the sexual
if sex doesn't present itself at least
you had a little snack
you know i'm saying you had a little bit
of you know you had that baby candy and
you got you know you got that erection
that body gun baby
you can take them any time day or night
you know you can even on a full stomach
don't matter
and since they're chewable they work up
to twice as fast as pills and that's
beautiful
because our you know the non-chewable
you take that thing
an hour later you don't know what's
going on you can't turn your neck your
cheeks are rock hard
it's scary blue chew is prescribed
online by licensed physicians
so you don't have to go to the doctor's
office or wait in line at the pharmacy
you don't have to let your neighbor see
you sneaking over there
to get a little [ __ ] pill you know to
get you a little freaking
you know that little petal
that that little that little wand pebble
they're made in the usa too no more of
these foreign ones
no more of these indi you know these
ones from india make your knees sweat
make your cartilage you know
deteriorating your body
that's bluechew.com promo code
theo to try it for free yep
this past weekend listeners support the
cast
blue chew and get your first shipment
free
when you use special promo code t-h-e-o
just pay five dollars shipping again
that's bluechew.com
promo code theo to try it free the
better cheaper faster
choice and we thank them for sponsoring
the podcast
[Music]
we had some some neat calls that came in
uh you know i was thinking this weekend
man i was
i was um you know recently in my life
i've been really stuck on
just the fear side of things
just really living from a place of fear
you know afraid to kind of make a choice
afraid to speak afraid to
you know there's just so much fear i
think out there in the air right now
that i i notice it for myself it's
starting to infect the other areas of my
body
in my life my action
you know i'm so scared to be
to try something to do something to take
an
action you know um
i'm so conf i'm so i'm just trying to
stay comfortable
and what i'm missing out on i realize is
the opportunity for adventure
you know for possibility
you know i was over there in tennessee
this weekend and and nashville is
beautiful man
and i start thinking well what would it
be like if i spent time here if i
you know was back and forth between the
two coasts and
you know what would it be like
you know it's like and then i just i
start to be like oh i can't imagine like
you know what you know i'd have to find
this would be new i i i need to get a
new
vehicle i need to get to get a new home
i need to get you know
all these things these
you know all these things i need to do
you know all these
fears really and i look at them as fears
i look at them as fears instead of as
opportunities instead of saying
oh man this could be exciting i i would
get to do i get to do
i get to do this i get to you know i get
to
see that i get to imagine what it's
gonna
instead i'm like oh man i have to do
this is you know
what about all
and just i just realized so much of my
life i live in the fear side
you know and i approach a lot of my days
and my
moments like that
whether i'm considering a new city or
whether i'm considering
even dating
you know i go into dayton like that oh
man i hope you know
i don't even give things a chance to be
love or to be
bigger than just a couple dates or just
a
a fly by night or a little touchy
you know i don't really give things the
opportunity it's just too
i just stay in the safety
and i'm just i just realized like man i
just how much possibility i miss out on
you know and just how much yeah just how
much
difference you know what how
just the risk of kind of letting go to
shore and just seeing what any other
rapids are
you know i don't know how somehow along
the way in my life i just got more
i just got i just got comfortable with
playing it safe
and i i think that's fine you know i
think it's fine to play it safe i just
you know i can play it safe when i'm
back in
the ether you know i can play it safe
when i'm back in the palm of god's hand
or in the ball sack of the the great
maker
you know i'm out here and so often i
just
get stuck you know i just don't want to
i just hold on to the branches of
comfort so much
and i didn't it's just before i even go
into things like i'll go i'll see
you know i'll stand right there and look
at the rapids and say how exciting they
are
but so rarely am i willing to just
really let
just just see what something new could
be like
um
yeah i just noticed that this weekend
because or this past week because i had
so much fear just being in a new place
and thinking about
just new opportunity and and i just i
leaned more into the fear
instead of the possibility
um
yeah it's like i i'm afraid of
i'm almost afraid of
just trusting life
you know i'm almost i'm afraid of just
trusting like a higher power
just trusting
that there's something new out there
that there's just i don't know i can't
explain it a little i'm just
i just
i always hedge my bets and some of that
smart
but man though just
how freeing it would feel to just say
you know what i'm gonna
see what comes
you know i'm gonna lean into
the wind and not into the
the the cliff side you know not into the
rock i'm gonna lean into
the i don't know
and
and not be as safe
because i need excitement i need i need
it's just it's such the juice that this
whole
guava is based on man
is that you know
it is just taking a chance sometimes
and being a little risque man um
yeah i'm not i don't i don't i just i
guess i i started to feel kind of
disappointed when i was like man
i went to nashville i checked it out i
was i was excited and then i got home
and i started to feel scared
i started to feel like oh man but i
everything's going okay here
and it's like yeah but maybe
everything's gonna be okay
no matter what maybe this will be maybe
something i need a challenge
you know i used to love the challenge so
much i used to love
to show the world i'm gonna do something
and somehow i got so sad in the safety
that all i the feeling i only even know
sometimes is the feeling of the net
against my back you know
that's safety
man just to i only uh you know i got so
accustomed to these training wheels
then i just i've lost some of the muscle
that it
that amazing muscle of balance of
balancing yourself as you ride
um we got some calls that came in
man let's get uh let's get into one or
two of them
um let me see what we got here
uh
here we go right here hi theo my name is
justin cart from nashville tennessee
what's up justin i was just in your area
brother
and you have a beautiful area down there
a lot of trees water
everything man you know electricity
everything maybe do it
just calling uh because this past
weekend
man a bunch of friends of mine went
camped out
at the tennessee river because uh
unfortunately one of our friends
took his own life a couple months back
and
we all just now got to do the memorial
because of the corvette pushing
everything back
and i just wanted to say that if anyone
out there is like
going through some [ __ ] and like don't
think they can talk to anybody
man just reach out to someone man
because your boys your family
like everyone's gonna miss you if
something happens and
no one likes that man and man everyone
just take care of yourself look out for
everyone you love
game game amen man thank you for that
i'm sorry to hear about your friend
yeah there's a lot of you know i've
worried recently a lot about um
you know a lot of my friends who
struggle with addiction they can't get
help right now
you know a lot of the aaa rooms have
shut down during this
you know there used to be meetings all
the time and then now if somebody's
struggling that
you know those those meetings aren't
there
and it's just so
i mean i don't know what's worse i can't
imagine what's worse i would i would
personally rather take the risk of dying
of uh the disease than
than not having aaa rooms be open
you know i have one party he man he's
been struggling so hard
you know going on benders for weeks at a
time and
i just keep telling hey man just hold on
you know just
because there's no there's not these
in-person meetings the zoom meetings
aren't the same
and so it's you know it's just so many
levels that people are being affected uh
by the separation of humanity you know
we need each other
that's why we got arms to re you know to
hug
to tickle
you know to pat that tit baby that's why
we have the
to reachers because we got to feel
something
this gentleman called with another line
here we go uh sorry man i forgot to
add one thing this is uh justin again
but uh after our memorial service we
went back to our campsite and uh
you know we all had a got a little
baggie of our boys
our boys remains we got some ashes you
know so oh yeah
that death dust baby oh yeah baby
gods eight balls son onward we came back
to the campsite throwed up a little
doobie
sprinkled our boy on there a little bit
of a boy on that
blowed him up to the sky man
he hit good though but uh he made the
joint run but i kind of figured he would
but
amen man and that's one way to do it
that's native american
smoking your friends body parts you know
you know cooking your buddy up straight
into your lungs that's native american
there's no other you know
that's how you do it put your buddy bowl
him up
smoke him out you know oh we were
cooking up little randall right now
you know we cooking up a little bowl of
steven r.i.p stephen
you know i remember we smoked up we had
a dude named lester brown we smoked his
little ass
he was real small you know he was just a
pony of a man
and we cooked his little ass up and
smoked him out of an apple praise god
man back in the day
and that's native american
you know anybody could bury their friend
and do you know
let's put him up there over by the hill
by the haunted house let's do that
you know anybody could have their friend
cremated and nothing let's throw them
out of this
you know let's throw them off the
parking garage or this
crown uh uh this um
crown plaza hotel out here near dayton
but to re really celebrate somebody if
you want to get back into the old ways
you got a body you know you take a sack
of that body dust
sprinkle it into a little gram dish bruh
and cook that bad bastard out
you know r.i.p barbara you know
you know give it a little pass that you
know past that freaking little
that jot past that john of lil henry's
low ass
and that's a way to show respect that's
called respect
so but i'm glad you guys enjoyed it man
you know it's funny you want to take
care of yourself you want to go into the
world smelling good feeling good
you know you want to go into the world
with creams and solutions on your skin
that
elevate you that let people know hey
this guy's a professional this guy
this guy don't want to smell like like
junk this guy don't want to look like
junk he wants to be
special well that's why i want to let
you know about
hawthorne and why you should give it a
try
hawthorne has a website you can go to
and you take a quiz a brief quiz that
they have set up
and they'll let you know what type of
smell good potions and feel-good
potions are right for your
style of human you know they ask you how
many times you
you know how busy are you what kind of
hairstyle you got
do you have a mustache basic things
that'll
that'll help them figure you out
and next thing you know they hit you
with uh with some easy to buy
online luxurious scented
goods yup
do you wear old spice well that's gotta
change do you wear ck one from high
school
that's gotta change you're gonna get the
sense
that hawthorne suggests
they'll give you one for work and one
for play
no one else has such personalized
products
all you do take a quick two minute
survey and hawthorne
tells you the two colognes that are best
for you and i said survey i mean quiz
it's risk free with free shipping and
free returns see how it works
throw a dab on your neck put a little
batch on your back see if things change
for you check out hawthorne.co
that's hawthorne with an e and use my
promo code
theo to get 10 off your first purchase
that's h a w t h o r
n e dot c o
and use my code theo to get 10 off
your first purchase hawthorne dot
co smell good get the accoutrements
you know different people make different
choices for their bodies
we had a call that came in right here
let's hear it
hey theo how you doing man my name is
jesse
uh i was a united states mariner
i was a mariner for about five years i
just recently got out man uh
calling in for some advice uh my dad
called me the other day he owns a strain
of motels
over there in flint michigan uh he's
been in the hotel business
my whole life and um oh yeah over there
in flint baby those dirty water motels
you know those brackish little bed shops
baby onward
he was telling me he wants to get a low
back tattoo and
dude i'm gonna tell you man you can't
you can do what you want but you also
can't get a low back tattoo if you were
a man
okay this ain't the future
this is right now and
that right there is a gateway drug to
homosexuality and probably
prison time and it's fine if that's what
if those are the things you're looking
for
but if you're just looking to do a
little snazzy body art
you don't get a back a lower back tattoo
especially if you slang in hotel rooms
man
you gonna have a couple fellows trying
to sleep up in your ass brother onward
being a straight single man i told them
i wouldn't recommend getting anything
tattooed on
on your lower back as a straight man but
um
you know he's my dad i want to respect
him i wanted to hear him out and he said
well
son i want to get the hotel logo
tattooed on my low back
well look man you know what actually bro
get it
i say you get dude get two flames coming
off the side coming right around to his
hips
the end of the flame just ending right
down towards his nuts
get that get a big huge banana right up
and down his spine man
and get the hotel or whatever it is
ramada you know
jerry's tight stay right there above his
ass get that
do them right treat your daddy right
what am i talking why am i saying
no when i should be saying yes
lean into the fun that's why
too much i'm i'm i'm telling say don't
do don't
lean into the fun take a chance
rent your daddy a nice brother with that
big body hammer for tonight
you know big uh big stanley big stanley
the stallion
you know what i'm saying get your get
your daddy dick down properly
out there let him live his life
i'm sorry i said no
i am sorry that i said no brother go on
and get it
and i hope your dad does it all i hope
he does it damn all dude and i hope he
probably does oral you know live a
little
pc baby praise christ
um let's take another call man right
here homework
what's going on theo this is billy
marshall
out of delray beach florida billy
and man i fell in love one time with a
girl from delray beach and
i met her on enter on twitter and we
texted and sex did and everything
sent drawings on my dick and everything
to her and she would
you know you know tell me what her
breasts felt like and everything and
describe it and send me
you know little envelopes and stuff like
that with perfume on the cotton and all
of that
but um
and we texted for months and months and
months and finally we saw each other and
we just it was just it was bafflingly
bad
we could not get along for [ __ ] so
anyway omar brother and uh
today was one of the craziest days i
ever had at work
i started working at this pest control
company in
february okay pest control
and we need it man i'd love to see a
real you know
a real little rodeo man out there just
corralling roaches
you know somebody on a quidditch broom
just chasing a bunch of bees trying to
get them bastards to chill out
trying to keep them away from a picnic
we need pest control we need somebody
out there wrangling these thoughts out
there
you know v g you know corralling these
[ __ ] into an urban outfitters or
something
and helping keep the world tight onward
and uh today they they're like all right
go out to the property and
go around the buildings and put your rat
baits out the contract with lumatrak if
you
know what that is oh yeah man killing
rats bro and it's
look when you come to the rat king you
talking about killing rats man you got a
lot of
uh nerve but i respect your position
onward you're in pest control but
anyways i'm doing the box
and after i do the box i look up and i
see
ten sharpshooters looking right at me
with the rifles like aimed right at me i
was like
i like looked at him i said what and
they said cut they waved me over i
walked over to him they said that
the bomb in that building and i i
changed the bait
while the bomb the bomb didn't end up
going off but
the bomb squad was there and i changed
the bait and then the bomb squad got me
but man that's one of those things too i
was high on marijuana like that's
that was an interesting experience high
on marijuana and there we go right there
and that's the truth of it all is that
pot can be a gateway drug man to
bombings
you do a little weed and somebody blows
up your [ __ ] cousin bro
you know you get high and suddenly you
think they got a you know
somebody taped a bunch of c4 up under
your silverado
so it's i've been high enough where i
feel like somebody's trying to bomb me
but
to just be high and then they and
there's real bombs
that's some [ __ ] that's some that's
awesome dude
dude i remember the drug dogs would come
to school
and they would come smell everybody in
the class and they said they were
smelling if you had any weed on you they
would know
and i remember raising my hand and i
said well what if you're just high
will they know that and uh
and the teacher and the police officers
were we're not happy
about that because i didn't have any
weed on me bro but i had that [ __ ] in my
brain
you know that so
um what else is going on man
what else they had some some neat calls
came in
uh all right let's get into
uh into this last call here as always
the hotline
nine eight five six six four nine
uh thank you guys for uh for being a
part of this episode and
we have some new items too new merch
items that are pretty neat
we got those hot hose hit shirts
featuring your boy little daniel out
there um
and uh and some other new items some
fresh rat king
vermin with the sermon hitters and uh
you can check all those out at theo von
i believe or through theovonne.com
and thank everybody for supporting this
podcast and for being a part of my life
you know i can't wait till the world
opens up and i can uh
get back to telling jokes and um
and thanks for just bearing with me you
know and we bear with each other
uh it's been a tough time man it's been
tough to
to stay in the joy you know there's a
lot of things out there
trying to divide us
you know trying to divide people by easy
things
um but you know we got to refuse to let
them do that
you know we have to refuse to do that
for ourselves you know
um you know i accept that
challenge i'm not going to let things if
i can't help it i'm going to work harder
to not let things take that love out of
me
you know i'm gonna lean into the things
that
are that are tough and just
put you know spread a couple of damn
pints of joy jam on my shoulders and
just lean head into it
and see if i can't sweeten the deal that
way
let's take one more call that happened
right here here we go gang
hey man uh my name is blake i just
wanted to
call i had some things to get off my
mind uh thanks for calling blake
onward my girlfriend just uh
just passed away of overdose uh like
sunday night
and um man i'm sorry to hear that man
i'm really sorry to hear that onward
you know the weight crying all night uh
and the podcast came out and uh at the
end the
evan barcelona song was on a thousand
times
and uh i don't know man it just
seemed like i could put everything you
know in the in the right perspective
like it was uh
like i've got to go on you know and
continue with life
and make her proud and uh because that's
what
you know that's what i imagined she was
going with me and that's what i would
want her if i was in
her position and uh
yeah and just uh it's been kind of rough
couple days man and uh
just know i just you do a really good
job of uh
bringing people that's
down uh in any kind of way you bring
their spirits up
uh just because i believe it's because
you've been there
you've been you've been to a shitty town
before and you've been through shitty
times before and you know
that you don't want other people to feel
like you did
so uh i think that's great man
uh love you man game game
love you too bro thanks for the nice
words man sorry
i'm so sorry to hear about your
girlfriend man um
you know i'm sorry to hear hear about
that
you know addiction that's powerful man
it's scary
and you know she didn't want that
she didn't want you know she didn't want
to
be addicted you know it's a real
i mean it is a real
it's a real dirty batman
that's out there man addiction uh
but thank you for the thank you for for
for just sharing what's going on with us
man i think it reminds us and
you know i don't want to be you know i
don't want this to be like a downer type
thing it's just
this is a reminder that that you know
that life is a gift that it did that
this is a fragile
bridge we're walking on
you know that this is a limited time
offer
and that we have to make the most of it
and that it's time to lean in
to life
it's time to lean into life for for all
the risk
and for all the reward you know
you know that's what it is it's a
it is a it is a chance for us to
feel risk and to experience it
and whether you whether that risk is
falling in love or
or trying a new job or trying a new
skill or
you know the those are the the
those are the those are the gifts man
those are the those those are the
that's the purpose of it
you know if i just stand the whole time
and i just stand in the safety of it all
then i'm not really getting the most out
of this vessel
and i'm not trying to to preach i'm just
trying to remind myself you know
just not to be afraid to try something
new
not to be afraid to walk into a
relationship with the possibility of it
being more
you know i'm just trying to remind
myself not to
not to be afraid to
to live man
to make mistakes and to make
non-mistakes whatever those are called
okay things
but either way just not to be afraid
just to live
but i'm sorry to hear about your girl
and thanks for the nice words man i
don't
you know i don't know what i'm doing
ever um
but being alive it's not easy
but i think it can be easier
if i'm just not that afraid sometimes
you know and it sounds like uh
that she would want you to be the type
of person that
that just goes on with brother
um anyway
i didn't mean to
you know and look you could always put
her in a joint
like your boys in them you know y'all
you could always roll up a j
of your lady and huff down and get
gassed out
praise god brother um
we're going to finish up uh
we'll we'll finish up right here
actually this man is out of nashville
now
by way of nebraska and uh we'll finish
up with
with some of his uh
song right there and we'll play it for
you and for your girls her spirit goes
on man
you know because i do believe that this
life here is just a park this is just a
parking spot
on a really really
wild ride
and we can do nothing with it or we
could put the tailgate down or the
the sunroof open and
and just be and just live it up
you know make the most out of this
parking lot
or you could park in the handicapped
spot illegally
and play a safe man
and i know we need a little bit of both
but
man i'm ready to take this placard this
fake handicap placard off of my dang
thing
and start to just live a little baby
um thank you for anybody that called in
and that was supportive of the podcast
this weekend
uh if anybody out there is going through
a tough time
you know just know that you're not alone
and that people are thinking of you
um and i'm gonna do my
let's just do our best to go out in the
world and be a part of other people's
joy
you know what happens if you show up to
work tomorrow with uh with a gift for
everybody
or with a different attitude what
happens if you show up tomorrow for
the boss that you hate and you get him
something nice you get him a little
necklace or something
or get him a little you know a thing of
saltwater taffy's or something from the
zoo
you know what happens then
what happens if i show up to my life
with a different vibe
you know what happens if instead of
coming at every day with a sword
i show up with a damn hug gun
and just start
just slanging hugs baby
just double arm and mf
this is evan bartels with a thousand
times you guys be good to yourself man
you deserve it okay
[Music]
and i'm sorry there's a little
it's a little
well this ain't sad it's just a little
beautiful man
it's a little beautiful
away baptizing empty skylines
with the whole better days
and i tell myself this will all be
fine
[Music]
thunder i remember i'm just a child
i would die
a thousand times
before i ever let
[Music]
and next week we're going to uh ring all
our single moms that we've
you know kept up with over the years and
uh just do a check in with them
you know we want to see what it's like
for them as they start to send the
kiddos back to school
and just get a couple of takes on it man
you know and check in with them magical
women man you know check in with them
beautiful muchas
that are the single mothers that keep a
lot of us going over the years and have
done so
um gang right there you know that
[Music]
[Applause]
i just throw the whole damn thing
to the fire
this will all be fine
i would die
a thousand times
before i ever let
you down
i wish it was easier
i wish i had more than
could give
i wish it was easier
i wish
give
[Music]
i would die
a thousand times
why
[Music]
and that is evan bartels right there
off his uh ep promised land
and you can purchase that out in there
on itunes or check it out how you
however you do music
barr tales um
a beautiful song man you know
a beautiful song you guys be good